schönen guten tag herr merz
größe sehr guten morgen olaf scholz sagt
nein kanzlerin merkel sagte olaf scholz
er sieht die politik das land bei ihm
jetzt in guten händen sehen sie das auch
so
[Musik]
wir haben gestern einen guten übergang
von der alten regierung zur neuen
regierung erlebt die demokratie in
deutschland funktioniert und es hat
einen guten übergang offensichtlich auch
in allen ministerien gegeben und jetzt
ist die neue regierung in der
verantwortung dass so ein übergang gut
funktioniert ist eine gute sache für
unser land und für unsere demokratie
diplomatische antwort die ich versuche
es trotzdem noch mal glauben sie ihr
scholz wird an unser kanzler also auch
ganz für sie persönlich ihr persönlicher
glaube daran
also mein persönlicher glaube spielt in
diesem zusammenhang glaube ich keine
rolle er hat jetzt eine neue regierung
hat alle chancen sie haben einen sehr
umfangreichen koalitionsvertrag gemacht
wir sind gespannt auf das was er jetzt
tut er tritt sein amt an in einer
außergewöhnlich schwierigen zeit es ist
mitten in der korona krise es sind am
horizont einige krisen sichtbar auch in
der außenpolitik also man muss das sehen
aus der sicht der opposition kann ich
nur sagen wir wünschen ihm erfolg für
unser land wir hoffen dass er erfolg hat
und dass er eine gute bundesregierung
führt und wenn er das nicht tut dann
werden wir das hier im parlament zur
sprache bringen dann wird darüber
diskutiert werden aber unsere hoffnung
heißt wir wollen eine gute und
erfolgreiche bundesregierung sind das
werden sie dann zur sprache bringen
sagen sie friedrich merz das erhoffen
sich ja viele in der cdu dass der
klartext gesprochen wird dass der
angreifen wird der friedrich merz die
csu sagt das schon sie kündigt einen
harten oppositionskurs an bei ihm klingt
es noch ein bisschen verhalten in dem
moment wann legen sie richtig los und
bei welchem thema
er weise vielen dank also für das
kompliment und für die erwartungen aber
zunächst einmal hat natürlich jede
regierung auch einen gewissen
vertrauensvorschuss
die ersten 100 tage wird es nicht sein
dafür ist die zeit zu schnelllebig dafür
sind auch die probleme zu groß aber wir
haben doch jetzt zunächst einmal die
zeit uns anzuschauen was diese regierung
macht und wir werden natürlich die rolle
in der opposition auch wahrnehmen auch
ausfüllen aber zunächst einmal ist jetzt
die regierung in der verantwortung und
das schauen wir uns an und
selbstverständlich werden wir dann auch
und dafür wird es sicher gelegenheiten
geben werden wir dann auch sehr klar und
sehr deutlich unsere meinung sagen auch
unsere alternativen entwickeln wir
werden nicht nur nein sagen sondern wir
werden auch sagen was man besser machen
könnte wenn wir uns sozusagen in der
rolle der regierung sehen würden
wir ja was die ampel durchhalten schafft
sie das und schafft sie das vielleicht
sogar noch länger
das weiß keiner voraus zu sagen wir
haben eine normale wahlperiode von vier
jahren es hat auch schon
bundesregierungen gegeben die weniger
geschafft haben denken sie an gerhard
schröder zurück der ist im laufe der
zweiten amtsperiode von seiner eigenen
partei faktisch entmachtet worden das
muss man sehen ich beobachte die dinge
mit großem interesse bis jetzt sind alle
spd bundeskanzler an der eigenen partei
gescheitert ob dies jetzt wieder so sein
wird wird man sehen wir haben eine
koalition übrigen die neu ist für
deutschland erstmalig aus drei
bundestagsfraktionen bestehend auch das
ist eine neue erfahrung die wir in
deutschland jetzt machen also diese
regierung hat jetzt alle chancen sie
muss sie nutzen und dann werden wir
darüber auch hier im parlament und in
der deutschen öffentlichkeit intensiv
diskutiert jetzt haben wir gerade
hierbei greift die ersten eindrücke
gesehen von angela merkel am tag danach
als sie raus ist aus dem kanzleramt wie
sie in durchs verschneite berlin geht
einsteigt zu ihrem ersten termin dann
sie steht für sie in einer reihe mit den
ganz großen kanzler adenauer brandt kohl
oder nicht herr merz
ohne zweifel ist sie eine große
bundeskanzlerin sie war die erste frau
in diesem amt alleine das hat zeichen
gesetzt und hat auch sicherlich zu recht
große aufmerksamkeit gefunden sie hat
dieses land übergeben in einem guten
zustand wir haben die niedrigste
arbeitslosigkeit seit der
wiedervereinigung wir haben das erste
mal in ihrer amtszeit ausgeglichenen
bundeshaushalt gesehen wir sind
anerkannt in der welt deutschland stimme
zählt das haben wir auch angela merkel
zu verdanken also olaf scholz tritt hier
in außergewöhnlich große schuhe
friedrich mehr als vielen herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch